[Music]
it has been a crazy week in america
let's find out what happened it was
reported this week that after president
biden's inauguration
former vice president mike pence took a
vacation to the u.s
virgin islands or as they were known
before he got there
the u.s islands
five of the attorneys on former
president trump's legal defense team
quit over the weekend
following a disagreement over strategy
the attorneys wanted to present an
airtight legal
argument while trump wanted to bust
through the wall of the senate like the
kool-aid man
you're fired according to
no one asked for it according to a new
report nintendo's profits
doubled during the pandemic but then
they ran into a turtle shell and shrank
back down
that was for you derek yeah i appreciate
it sometimes you gotta throw tarik a
monologue joke he really is appreciative
i'm gonna be thinking about that all day
i love him cause he's nerdy
six people in california were arrested
this week for allegedly
changing the hollywood sign to read
quote holly boob
bail was set at fifty eight thousand and
eight
dollars it was announced that the
director of the film
black panther will develop a tv show for
disney plus that is set in wakanda
and it looks pretty cool okay
okay the power of the blade
away
according to a new study naked mole rats
from different locations have their own
distinct dialects
though for what it's worth the phrase
naked mole rat is considered offensive
in all of them national fart day was
today and
any day i eat ice cream
and finally it was reported this week
that engineers at mit have developed a
spinach plant
that is capable of sending emails and
here's the first one
and that was the monologue hey tarek
sing that little song you used to sing
when you were in menudo i was never in
menudo
everyone at some point has been in
menudo okay
enough of this back to the news now
you probably read a bunch of headlines
over the past two weeks about this
fiasco that's going on between people on
reddit and some hedge funds that have
been taking advantage of the gamestop
stock
and you know i would love to cover it on
the show but
the truth is that i don't fully
understand what's going on
oh finally my time to shine i understand
it completely
you want me to explain you can try but
i've been reading articles and watching
videos about it for two weeks
the second my brain tries to process
anything about the stock market
i just shut down completely and start
thinking about some other nonsense
well then i'll make it real simple for
you okay
so this pen here this is the gamestop
stock and this pen here is the hedge
fund
melvin capital so a while ago melvin
capital
shorted the gamestop stock you know what
i just remembered
that brian mcknight song back at one
that's a good song
but those lyrics do not make any sense
one you're like a dream come true
two just wanna be with you three girl
that's plain to see
those aren't that weird but then he goes
four repeat steps one through three
what those were steps there aren't any
instructions there
even as a love song saying repeat steps
one through three is crazy
he just needed something to rhyme with
the next line
i love that man but he should have done
a second draft of this so
amber huh were you paying attention
yes okay no i was thinking about
something else i'm sorry
i'm really trying it's just all so
confusing and boring sounding
it's okay it took me a while too here uh
let me try another way
okay so here's a chart and on this
x-axis we have gamestop and on this
y-axis
we have hedge fund investments okay so
you know what else i just remembered
that casey and jojo song
all my life damn that's a great song but
the lyrics on that song are crazy too
close to me you're like my father close
to me you're like my sister
what are you doing you can't put that in
the first verse
if someone i loved told me i was like
their father or their sister
i am running like hell or at least
warning their dad and sister that
they've got some romantic entanglements
they're gonna need to sort out on their
own
amber what's that are you listening oh
yeah
okay what did i just say uh
well it was definitely something about
stocks right oh amber come on
it's really not that confusing it sounds
confusing the second you say stock
market or short selling or whatever
it's like a code word for my brain to
turn off you're gonna have to dumb it
way down
okay okay fine all right uh all right i
have
another example let's say that you
have an apple and you know that this
apple is worth
two dollars you know what i just
remembered
that song party all the time honestly
perfect song
doesn't get enough credit i have no
notes but
the video however why the hell are there
two people playing guitar in that music
video
there ain't one damn guitar in the whole
song as if
that's not enough rick james comes in at
the end and picks up yet
another guitar there are three more
people playing guitar in this video
than there are playing guitar on the
actual song that's just sloppy
who was in charge of this shoot wait no
amber
stop getting distracted tarik is trying
to help pay attention oh
okay now i'm starting to get it you're
doing a great job keep going
amber i finished two minutes ago
oh it's all right let me guess you were
thinking about the party all the time
music video
yes why do they have so many guitarists
in that video
i don't know i can't explain that i
can't explain that either
but i love eddie murphy
okay maybe we should just move on now as
i'm sure i don't need to remind you the
last four years in america
were awful and we want to make sure the
next four are better so
i'd like to outline some ways we can do
that in a segment called
what we not going to do
joe biden has a peloton bike and the new
york times is upset about it
in a recent article they wrote it
doesn't exactly comport with this
regular joe from scranton persona
here's the deal having a peloton you
bought with your own money when you're
married to a doctor is not elitist
predictable yes but not elitist this man
spent 2 000 of his
own dollars for an exercise bike trump
spent an estimated 140 million
of our tax dollars on personal golf
trips so
what we're not going to do is act like
these two men are the same
they are not we're also not going to
write a bunch of op-eds about trump
voters feeling unheard
if you're talking to cnn or the new york
times girl we hear you
you know who actually deserves to be
heard the black americans who despite
everything this country has done to
suppress their rights
still came out and voted so what we're
not going to do is spend the next four
years talking to people who lost the
election
we're not going to invite lying liars on
tv to let them lie
we are not going to reach across the
aisle to hold hands with
insurrectionists
you could lose a hand we are not going
to act like this man should be on talk
shows instead of on
medication we are not going to normalize
this this or frankly this
help him what is that does anybody know
the last 10 months have been hard and
the last four years have been garbage we
have a real opportunity to make some
vital changes in this country so
spending time worrying about pelotons
and nonsense is a wasted opportunity and
that's just something we're not going to
do
and now it's time for a new segment from
my good friend tariq
take it away tarek
[Music]
thanks amber hello everyone and welcome
to taric sports minute
where we cover all news and sports in
just one minute
all right whoa whoa whoa what what's up
taric sports minute yeah this is going
to last for a whole minute
more or less nope sorry no way we do not
have an entire minute to devote
to sports well then why did you approve
taric sportsman
i thought that was the joke like how
could we possibly talk about sports for
an entire minute
i mean what would it even be about like
the scores or
the scores do you watch this show
the only scores we talk about are by
rogers and hammerstein
aaron rodgers oh the quarterback for the
packers
don't do not start the super bowl is
this weekend i thought we could try
something new
and you went with sports there's already
an entire channel devoted to sports
it's called espn i think is there a
whole channel devoted to bob fosse
parodies
no what about deep dives on redlining
not that i know of
what about a little soul patch that
flies around the studio and lands on
people's faces
maybe on nick jr no tarik they're not
doing that on nick jr
they're not doing it anywhere except
here but we can't do that today because
we're knee-deep in the single most
boring topic of conversation i can
imagine just get to the song
oh oh there was supposed to be a song
there's no
song tarik you're killing me
do you know how angry our viewers are
going to be when they realize that this
doesn't pay off in some sort of
excellent musical parody
pretty upset vivid you'll be canceled
tarek that's a given
there's nothing we can do about that at
this stage career-wise you will not
bounce back but maybe
just maybe we can still save the show
damn okay uh what do i got to do
you have to sing taric okay with your
whole heart
okay okay um are you ready for some
football
no not that anything but that um
okay uh i don't wanna be anything other
than what i've been trying to be lately
degraw i i don't know whatever just keep
singing
sing with me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
you